William and Louise are in different
physics classes at Santa Rita Louise's
teacher always gives exams with 30
questions on them while Williams teacher
gives more frequent exams with only 24
questions
Louise's teacher also assigns three
projects per year even though the two
classes have to take a different number
of exams their teachers have told them
that both classes let me underline both
classes will get the same total number
of exam questions each year what is the
minimum number of exam questions
Williams or Lewis's class can expect to
get in a given a year so let's think
about what's happening so if we think
about Louis's teacher who gives 30
questions per test so after the first
test he would have done 30 questions
then after so this is zero right over
here then after the second test he would
have done 60 then after the third test
he would have done 90 and after the
fourth test he would have done 120 and
after the fifth test if there is a fifth
test he would do so this is if they had
that made test he would get to 150 total
questions and we could keep going on and
on looking at all the multiples of 30 so
this is probably a hint of what we're
thinking about working at multiples of
the numbers we want the minimum
multiples or the least multiple so
that's what Louise well what's going on
with William well William's teacher the
first after the first test they're going
to get 224 questions
24 then they're going to get 248 after
the second test then they're going to
get to 72 72 after the third test then
they're going to get to 96 I'm just
taking multiples of 24 they're going to
get to 96 after the fourth test and then
after the fifth test they're going to
get to 120 and if there's a sixth test
then they would get to 144 they would
get to 144 and we could keep going on
and on and there let's see what they're
asking us what is the minimum number of
exam questions Williams or Lewis's class
can expect to get in a year well the
minimum number is the point at which
they've gotten the same number of exam
questions despite the fact that the
tests had different number of items and
you see the point at which they have the
same number is that a
and 20 this happens at 120 they both can
have exactly 120 questions even though
Lewis's teachers giving 30 at a time and
even though Williams teachers giving 24
at a time and so the answer is 120 and
notice they had a different number of
exams Lewis had one two three four exams
while William would have to have one two
three four five exams but that gets them
both to 120 total questions now thinking
of it in terms of some of the math
notation or the or the least common
multiple notation we've seen before this
is really asking us what is the least
common multiple of 30 and of 30 and 24
and that least common multiple is equal
to is equal to 120 now there's other
ways that you can find the least common
multiple other than just looking at the
multiples like this you can look at it
through prime factorization 30 is 2
times 15 which is 3 times 5 so we could
say that 30 is equal to 2 times 3 times
5 and 24 24 that's a different color in
that blue 24 is equal to 2 times 12 12
is equal to 2 times 6 6 is equal to 2
times 3 so 24 24 is equal to 2 times 2
times 2 times 3 so another way to come
up with the least common multiple if we
didn't even do this exercise up here it
says look the number has to be divisible
by both 30 and 24 if it's going to be
divisible by 30 it's going to have to
have 2 it's going to have to have 2
times 3 times 5 in its prime
factorization that is essentially 30 so
this makes it divisible by 30 and say
well in order to be divisible by 24 it's
going to need to its prime factorization
is going to need 3 2s and a 3 well we
already have one 3 and we already have 1
2 so we just need 2 more twos so 2 times
2 so this makes it so this makes it let
me score
a little bit this right over here makes
it divisible by 24 and so this is
essentially the prime factorization of
the least common multiple of 30 and 24
you take any one of these numbers away
you are no longer going to be divisible
by one of these two numbers if you take
a 2 away you're not going to be
divisible by 24 anymore if you take a 2
or 3 away if you take a if you take a if
you take a 3 or a 5 away you're not
going to be divisible by 30 anymore and
so if you were to multiply all these out
this is 2 times 2 times 2 is 8 times 3
is 24 times 5 is it is 120 now let's do
one more of these
oh mama just bought one package of 21
binders we write that number down 21
binders she also bought a package of 30
pencils 30 pencils she wants to use all
of the binders and pencils to create
identical sets of office supplies for
her classmates what is the greatest
number of identical sets
well mam what can make using all of the
supplies so the fact that we're talking
about greatest is clue that it's
probably going to be dealing with
greatest common divisors it's also
dealing with dividing these things we
want to divide these both into the
greatest number of identical the
greatest number of identical sets so
there's a couple of ways we could think
about let's think about what the
greatest common divisor of both these
numbers are or I could even say the
greatest common factor the greatest
common divisor of 21 21 and 30 so what's
the largest number that divides into
both of them so we could go with the
prime factor we could list all of their
normal factors and see what is the
greatest common one or or we could say
we could we could look at the prime
factorization so let's just do the prime
factorization method so 21 is the same
thing as 3 times 7 these are both prime
numbers 30 is let's see it's 3 I check
it write it this way it is 2 times 15 we
already did it actually just now and 15
is 3 times 5 so what's the greatest
what's the largest number of prime
numbers that are
into both factorizations well you only
have a three right over here there
you'll have a three times anything else
so this is just going to be equal to
three so this is essentially telling us
like let's divide both of them in the
let we can divide both of these numbers
into three and that will give us the
largest number of identical sets so just
to be clear of what we're doing so we've
answered the question it's three but
just to visualize it for this question
let's actually draw 21 21 binders so
let's say the 21 binders so 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20
21 and then 30 pencils so I'll just do
those in green so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
let me just copy and paste that lets
getting tedious so copy and paste so
that's 20 and then paste that is 30 now
we figured out that 3 is the largest
number that divides into both of these
evenly so I can divide both of these
into groups of 3 so for the binders I
can do it into 3 groups of 7 and then
for the for the pencils I could do it
into 3 groups of 10 so if there are 3
people that are coming into this
classroom I could give them each 3 I can
just give them each 7 binders and 10
pencils but that's the greatest number
of identical sets who mamuh can make I
would have 3 sets each set would have 7
binders and 10 and 10 pencils and we
essentially just thinking about what's
the greatest what's the great the number
that we can divide both of these sets
into evenly the largest number that we
can divide both of these sets into
evenly